esto es periodismo llegaron a Canadá
hace menos de una semana
pero estos dos solicitantes de asilo
dicen que es la primera vez en mucho
tiempo que se sienten seguros en México
la situación de seguridad no es buena es
muy peligroso para nosotros
por los narcos y otras cosas
te pueden secuestrar sin razón alguna y
después hasta te pueden matar o pedirle
dinero a tu familia
era terrible para nosotros
como ellos decenas de migrantes viven en
este edificio del gobierno de Quebec
mientras esperan obtener la condición de
refugiados todos acaban de llegar a
Canadá después de meses o en algunos
casos años de viaje
primero queremos establecernos aquí en
Montreal aprender francés
conseguir un trabajo y después queremos
traer a nuestras familias
porque aquí puede haber un futuro y
seguridad
es un fenómeno reciente la cantidad de
solicitantes de asilo que llegó en avión
se disparó en los últimos meses según
inmigration Canadá de un poco más de
1600 en 2021 pasaron a ser alrededor de
12.000 en 2022 los responsables del
programa Regional de acogidas señalan
que entre ellos hay muchos mexicanos
en este momento principalmente son
personas que vienen de América del Sur
México es el primer país del que
recibimos gente está claro que las
personas buscan un lugar donde poder
vivir seguras para quienes tienen una
familia también significa garantizar que
su familia tenga un futuro mejor pero
cada persona tiene un recorrido único el
año pasado México fue el segundo país de
origen de los solicitantes de asilo A
diferencia de los migrantes provenientes
de Colombia hay tío Nigeria los
mexicanos no necesitan visa para entrar
a Canadá simplemente tienen que llenar
un formulario el ave que los autoriza a
quedarse hasta seis meses en territorio
canadiense si no tienes un pasaporte
tienes que pagar por un coyote pero si
tienes un pasaporte te sale más barato
pagar por un avión desde la Ciudad de
México que son entre 25.000 y 30 mil
pesos cuando un coyote te puede cobrar
más de 100 000 pesos Esteban era
periodista en México por razones de
seguridad mantendremos su anonimato
estoy escribiendo acerca de crímenes
cometidos por el gobierno
recibí amenazas del Cartel de Nueva
Generación quienes tienen presencia en
todo México empezaron a decir que bueno
no me metí en lo que no me importaba que
ya sé cómo es la situación con los
periodistas en México y que si no quería
ser uno de ellos
[Música]
pues que me callara no Esteban ha estado
solicitando asilo desde que llegó ahora
trabaja con su primo como mecánico pero
estuvo varios meses haciendo trabajos
clandestinos y peligrosos
de Colombia muchos mexicanos obviamente
mexicanos son trabajos físicos en donde
tienes que cargar muchas cosas pesadas
en donde si tú te rompes un brazo si tú
te rompes una pierna pues
no tienes No tienes ninguna seguridad no
tienes derecho a visitar un médico son
trabajos que la gente de aquí de ninguna
forma va a ser la situación migratoria
de Esteban debería resolverse en las
próximas semanas su expediente está en
manos de la comisión de inmigración y
refugiados de Canadá y de su abogado
nos vamos a ver entonces la semana que
viene hasta según su abogado gracias a
las múltiples pruebas de su perse El
joven periodista tiene altas
posibilidades de obtener la condición de
refugiado pero no todos los mexicanos
que vienen a pedir asilo a Canadá corren
con la misma suerte
a nivel general podríamos decir que en
el caso de México los solicitantes de
asilo que vienen a pedir asilo a Canadá
tienen una tasa de aceptación del 30%,
durante la pandemia la solicitudes de
asilo de México estaban casi en cero
incluso antes de la pandemia eran 500
600 pero el año pasado llegamos a 8.000
9.000 solo en Quebec incluso nos hacen
falta abogados especializados en
inmigración los migrantes que no
obtienen el asilo son enviados de
regreso a México otros optan con la
clandestinidad y prueban suerte cruzando
la frontera Sur hacia Estados Unidos es
difícil explicar este aumento repentino
de las cifras Pero según algunas ong la
difusión de videos en redes sociales
podría ayudar esta publicación que habla
sobre la política de inmigración
supuestamente flexible de Canadá tiene
más de 13 millones de vistas por lo
tanto necesitan gente lo mejor de todo
es que esto no abre la puerta a los
trabajadores profesionales sino también
aquellos que tengan oficios no
profesionales antes del aumento de la
presión y de la cantidad de personas el
sistema de asilo canadiense podría
reconsiderar sus normativas de frontera
con México pero según este especialista
en políticas públicas de inmigración
este no será el caso
se quiere mantener la libertad de los
acuerdos en particular de los acuerdos
comerciales entre 2009 y 2016 los
mexicanos estuvieron obligados a pedir
una visa para entrar a Canadá si uno
mira por ejemplo los periódicos de esa
época verá que los presidentes mexicanos
que estuvieron en el gobierno estaban
muy disgustados por ese tema y en 2016
Justin trudeo decidió suspender la
obligación de que los mexicanos
necesitarán una visa para entrar a
Canadá
molestar a uno de los socios del tratado
de libre comercio norteamericano firmado
en 2018 está fuera de discusión sin
embargo los servicios sociales de ayuda
para los migrantes previenen sobre el
riesgo de que aumenten las redes
clandestinas de empleadores y coyotes
entre Canadá y Estados Unidos